[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانب
فيديو
اسبابه الغرب بدا يمل وروسيا صححت تمركزها
رغم خساره النواب بايضا قادر على تسجيل
اهداف اجنده ليس كمهاجم وانما كمدافع
والصفقات قد ترضي الجميع
[موسيقى]
هراوته الامن الايرانيه تلاحقوا شبح مهسا
اميني في القطارات ضرب وسحل واهانه وقتيل
جديد لم يتخطى التاسعه
لدينا ايضا
في ازمه افلاس منصه اف تي اكس تهامات
للملاك بالاحتيال ولاجهزه ماليه بالاهمال
والكونغرس يقحم نفسه
[موسيقى]
في الحرب الاوكرانيه كل يوم هناك حدث حدث
دموي على الاغلب اليوم بات التركيز على
تداعيات القصف الروسي المكثف الذي استهدف
منشات مهمه للغاز والبنيه التحتيه
الجنوبي ومدينه برو في وسط البلاد ما دفع
السلطات لمطالبه المدنيين بالاحتماء
وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الرئيس الروسي
لحرمان الملايين الملايين من الناس من
الكهرباء
اعتبر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
بلانكن ان روسيا ستتحمل المسؤوليه في
نهايه المطاف لانها هي التي تمطر اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ وتضطرها للدفاع عن نفسها
سقط الصاروخ الاوكرانيه في الاراضي
البولنديه بالخطا وانهالت الانتقادات على
القياده الاوكرانيه وعلى الرئيس فرض ميرسي
بسرعه الصاروخ او اكثر الرئيس الاوكراني
اصر على تحميل روسيا المسؤوليه رغم تاكيد
وارسو والنيتو ان الصاروخ اوكراني اوكراني
شارد مع الاصرار على ان المسؤوليه
الاساسيه تبقى على روسيا التي امطرت ولا
تزال تمطر سماء جارتها الغربيه بالصواريخ
اسراره وسنسكي فتح عليه باب الاتهامات
خاصه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي فكثيرون
راوا انه يحاول جرا نيته والعالم لحرب
العالميه الثالثه متهمين الرئيس واركان
قيادته بالكذب وهو اتهام كثيره
كرتون
توم وجيري توم وجيري
[موسيقى]
الترامب بالابن على تويتر قائلا انه بما
ان صاروخ اوكرانيا هو الذي اصاب بولندا
وهي حلفتنا في الناتو فهل يمكننا على
الاقل توقف عن انفاق المليارات لتصليحهم
الان هو تساؤل ليس بريئا ذلك الذي اطلقه
ترامب للابن اذن لكن الاصرار الاوكراني
على تحميل المسؤوليه لروسيا ربما تكون
الاجابه عليه في دخول الشتاء وفي ظهور
مؤشرات على التراجع الدعم الغربي لكن
رسميا لا شيء معلنا حتى الان ولا مؤشرات
على تراجع هذا الدعم اطلاقا بل لاننا
تنتجون اكاد استمرار المساعده خرج الوزير
اوستن ليعدد مزايا انظمه الدفاع الجوي ده
سامز التي كانت اوكرانيا من التصدي
لاغلبيه الصواريخ الروسيه
[موسيقى]
سبب اخر لقلق زنسكي وهو خريطه سيطره
الميدانيه التي تتغير بشكل شبه يومي منذ
انسحاب روسيا من خرسان وهنا يتوقع محللون
عسكريون نقاطا ساخنه جديده واشتداد القتال
في الشرق وبتجاه مدن بحر ازوف في الجنوب
من المرجح ان تكون النقاط الساخنه التاليه
بالقرب من دنيا في منطقه دومبرز الشرقيه
ولا سيما بالقرب من مدينتي ضخموت وافديفكا
هناكثف وفي الجنوب في طريقهم الى مدينه
بول وماريوبل الاستراتيجيتين يشير محللون
الى انه من المرجح ان تجدد روسيا تركيزها
على الشرق بعد انسحابها في الجنوب وسيكون
ذلك تحولا في استراتيجيات الكراملين بعد
ان اعلنت موسكو عن مرحله جديده من الحرب
تهدف الى التحرير الكامل لمن تقدم بصمه
يقرا محللون انسحاب روسيا من غير سون بانه
قد يصب في مصلحه الكاملين الذي يسمح
لروسيا بنقل الموارد بعيدا عن الجنوب
وتعزيز قواتها على طول الخط خط الجبهه
الشرقيه ووافقه معلومات نقالتها
فانما يصل الى 50% من القوات الروسيه
المنصبه من خرسان يمكن نقلها الى جبهات
اخرى
مواقع دفاعيه جديده مهمه ايضا وضعوا قد
يشبروا كيف قد يجبرها على اعاده توجيه
القوات نحو الجنوب بقى من الجنوب واعاده
نشر قوات اضافيه في دوناتسك كي لا تسمح
للرؤوس بالتقدم
الاهم ان تحاول اوكرانيا نشر قواتها في
هجوم بري جديد محتمل بين الجبهتين الشرقيه
والجنوبيه خاصه وان استغلال عنصر المفاجاه
كان حاسما سابقا ووصفه خبراء بانه كان
تكتيكا ذكيا للغايه
[موسيقى]
في كل الاحوال ومع اجواء الطقس غير
المواطيه غرد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
تعمل مع حلفاء دوليين لبناء نظام الدفاع
الجوي متكامل ومنسق لان حمايه السماء
الاوكرانيه اولويه تعاهدت كندا من جهتها
بان تكون في طليعه الداعمين واعلن رئيس
وزراءها جاستن ترودو تقديم 500 مليون
دولار كمساعده عسكريه لكيف وهو في الوقت
ذاته فرض عقوبات على ما يقرب من 20 كيانا
روسيا اما واشنطن في يبدو انها تقرا القصف
الروسي المكثف كما يجب رئيس هيئه الاركان
الجنرال مارك مالي اعتبر ان الهجمات على
البنا التحتيه تشكل جرائم حرب وحمله
ارهابيه بعد خساره موسكو على كل الجبهات
مالي اضاف ان روسيا تختار استغلال وقتها
في محاوله اعاده تنظيم صفوفها وتفرد حمله
من المعاناه
قصوى على سكان المدنيين الاوكرانيين بهدف
هزيمه الروح المعنويه الاوكرانيه قبيل
الشتاء
معنا من كيف فولدوميرشوماكو دبلوماسيه
سابق اهلا بك معنا سيد ضمير في العربيه
360 اذا العالم يتهمكم اليوم بان همم يعني
كيف على الاقل كانت قاب قوسين او ادنى من
توريط العالم بحرب عالميه ثالثه بناءا على
معلومات مدسوسه او مغلوطه او متعمده همم
فيما الغرب حتى الذي يقف معكم وقف ضد هذه
المعلومات ولي يوقفنا تسميه موسكو بهذا
التزييف للحقائق
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته وعليكم
استفزازي ولكن جميل بصراحه ههه
هو قادر بتغير النظام او تغير السياسه
امريكا او السياسه
نحن وجد بكره مثلا هذه الصواريخ التي سقطت
لاراضي بولنديه
صواريخ روسيه وبيان وروسيا كاس افريقيا
نحن
ده سقوط هذه الصواريخ كمان بنسبه لي كيجيب
بماسي سابق وكما راجع الاعمال بنسبه لغريب
تصريحات الصعيد
بدون اي حصوله عليها همم
الورقه الرسميه على التقرير من اللازم
لتفتيش الدوليه يعني
الموضوع يعني الغرب لا يبدو حائرا في
الواقع كان متاكدا جدا وحسم الشك باليقين
عندما يعتبر بانه همم يعني واضح ما حصل
بالنسبه اليه وحتى تصريحات من قبل دول
اوروبيه شرقيه كانت واضحه في هذا الاطار
الوحيد الذي ضل مصرا على كلامه هو سيد
زيلانكي
نحن نستطيع ان اقول كل شيء على يقين عندما
سوف نحصل على تقرير رسمي امين هذه التفتيش
الدوليه هذا منطقي بصراحه بعد ذلك من
الممكن ان يقعش ولكن على كل حال حتى
يذكرنا هذا الصواريخ وكرانيه
بسبب عدم استهداف
الصواريخ الروسيه
مسؤوليه على هذا الكارث لماذا هي عملت
تتخص الصاروخيه على ارض اوكراني او الامس
الفتره يعني من المعروف اطلقت 100 صاروخ
قد هذا المايك غير معقول بصراحه بالنسبه
لي همم
في هذه النقطه تحديدا التي نناقشها اذا ما
كانت الصواريخ الروسيه فعلا سادفت الاراضي
البولنديه او انها كانت همم يعني على هامش
هذه الحرب وكان صاروخا دفاعيا اوكرانيا
مثلا
يعني بغض النظر العامه اذا كان دفاعيا ام
لا الان هل تعتقدون بان همم
باتيو به همم تلميحا وليس تصريحا بانه
يمكن ان يكون فيه شيء من الحقيقه بمعنى
التململ الغربي الحاصل خاصه اذا ما تغيرت
دفه القياده في الولايات المتحده وفي دول
اوروبيه اخرى
ممكن بصراحه ولكن بالصفه عامه انا لا اظن
بان سوف يتغير السياسه
حول روسيا ان نحن نشهد بان كمان هذا
الكاري في بولاندا همم لن يتغير اي شيء
بصراحه هذا كمان يختي كبار اللي همم
كمان هيشوفها هل ناقص الصوفي يجتاز وهذا
اختبار ما هو الرد سوف يكون همم
هل سوف تكون التعزيز قواتها في بولاندا او
حتى في اوكراني انا قطعتها ولذلك بصفه
عامه انا لا اعتقد ان سوف تكون تغيرات
كبيره ولكن في اني واحد ان احنا نشهد
بانغرب هو مستعد لتقديم انا مساعد
اوكرانيه وكما نحن اساميه هو مستعد بان
تعامل هذا النظام دفاعات جوي مشتركه
متكامل يعني وهذا وقت يعتقد البعض وهو ما
يلمح اليه الروس احيانا تصريحا وليس فقط
تلميحا بانه الامريكان قادرين على ان
يضغطوا عليكم متى شاؤوا لكي تدخلوا في هذه
المفاوضات الجديده والروس على فكره يعني
في التصريحات الاخيره يضعون كلمه مفاوضات
بين كل جمله
انا انا بصراحه كمان اعطاك موجود ضغط على
حكومه اوكرانيه همم
سلطه امريكيه على فكره هذا رائع بصراحه
ولكن ان نحن سمينه تصريحات سيليانسكي خلال
هذه الايام حتى اليوم
وهو مستعد بصفه عامه همم
يكون هذا المفاوضات مفتوحه اون لاين يعني
وهذا كمان مهمه جدا ولكن نحن هنا كان
مجتمعه يعني نحن غير مستعدين للمفاوضات
يعني
مفاوضات وللاسف شديد في الناصل الدقيقه
وهو يطلق هو الصواريخ على اوكرانيا
تحتيه عسكريه
اساسيه
حضرتك
ولن تج روسي على هذه الطاوله اذا كانت
خاسره تماما بالمعنى الاستراتيجي وليس
بالمعنى التكتيكي وقالها بال- بالامس انه
لن نسمح بخساره استراتيجيه لروسيا في هذا
المجال
بصراحه روسيا فاشله هذا حرب استراتيجين
وجي وسييسين كما يقولون
اهداف الاولى في روسيا كان هذا غير نظام
في اوكرانيا وبعدين كل شهر روسيا تقللوا
اهدافها نحن نتذكر رؤوس من كي- من تراجع
من شمال اوكراني من سومه
هزيمه مخزيه روسيا في خير
سقوط مدينه
كل شهر اهداف
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه معنا
وفرضي من الشبكه الديبلوماسيه سابق من
كييف ما بعرف زنقطع الخط طيب يبدو انهم
قطع الخط ولكن في الوقت المناسب شكرا
جزيلا على كل هذه الايضاحات تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
نبقى في تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه ففي
مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال كابير مستشار
دفاع البريطانيه لشؤون الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا الفريق طيار مارتن سامسونج قال ان
استخدام روسيا للمسيرات الايرانيه يظهر
فشلها في الميدان
[موسيقى]
ايران
وهذا يدل على الفشل الروسي العلاقه مع
ايران هي مؤشر على العلاقه التي لم تؤدي
الى النجاح ايران لديها تاريخ في زعزاعه
استقرار المنطقه والتصرف بسلوك لا يرغب به
احد في بادئ الامر ايران تجاهلت وانكرت
هذا الامر لكنها الان تعترف بتزويدها
روسيا بالمسيرات العلاقه بين روسيا وايران
العربيه القاسم في العربيه 360 ايضا
الضغط يزيد على ايران بعد قرار من وكاله
الطاقه ندد بمواقفها وحذرها من عدم
التعاون
[موسيقى]
انا حسيت الاسنان مشكله شائعه مره معجون
سنسداين المطور ترميم حمايه الجديد بيدخل
لعمق السن وهذا بيساعد فانه يقلل من
حساسيه الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم ما
يهملوا مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
[موسيقى]
يد الام ياما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
[موسيقى]
الحياه عذاب وقت ما تقدر تاخذ
يزيل احتقان الانف ست مرات اسرع من الحبوب
ويساعدك على التنفس بشكل
كل يوم يدل علينا
يفتح امامنا افاق جديده
نلتقي
نحو المستقبل
مهما اتسع العالم باعيننا
شغفنا
ياخذنا في رحله لنكتشف
التغيرات من حولنا الاحداث بسرعه
علينا ان نجزا بساعه واحده ما مات شعبت
مواضيعها
انساليه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
[موسيقى]
الرابعه نشرتكم
يوميا على شاشه العربيه
دال يساعد على تعزيز مناعتك يوم بعد يوم
خلي سندروم جزء من روتينك اليومي
[موسيقى]
يساعد في وقت تاثير التسلسلي لامراض اللثه
الان بمذاق محسن جديد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
في التويتر اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ يبدو انهم
يتهمون لهم ماسك بالتاثير سلبا على عاملين
النزاهه والامان في المنصه نحن سنتابع هذا
الموضوع لاحقا ولكن نبقى في شان الامريكي
فبفارق ضئيل جدا انتزع جمهوريون الغرفه
الاولى الادنى من الكونغرس مجلس النواب
لتكون مفاصل الحكم في واشنطن منقسمه لكن
ما الذي يعني ايه انقسام الحكومه في
واشنطن وكيف سيؤثر هذا على الرئيس جو بايد
من خلال العامين المتبقيين من عمره من
المرشح ان يكون ماذا نفود الجمهوريين
محدودا بسبب اداءهم في الانتخابات المصريه
والذي لم ياتي بموج حمراء كما كان متوقعا
سيطره الج ضيقه على مجلس النواب يتوقع ان
تعرق النسبيا فرص اي تشريع رئيسي لبيضن
سيكون رئيس ديمقراطي مضطرا للتعامل مع
قياده معارضه له في مجلس النواب
فالجمهوريون قالوا انهم يخططون للضغط عليه
لخفض الانفاق الحكومي واجراء تغييرات
سياسيه اخرى من خلال التهديد بحسب الاموال
المخصصه لابقاء تمويل الحكومه مستمرا
اضافه لذلك يقول القاده الجمهوريون ان
خططهم تشمل تعزيز امن الحدود وتقييد
الاجهاض والتشجيع المزيد من الاجور لعناصر
الشرطه وهو ما يخالف تماما سياسه بايدن
وسياسات الديمقراطيه ايضا سيكون الرئيس في
موضع الدفاع عندما يستخدم
للتحقيق مع الاداره وعائله الرئيس خاصه
لجهه نجله هانتربوينت الذي قال جمهوريون
ان تحقيقا بشانه بدا بالفعل كما قد تشمل
تحقيقات الجمهوريين المجمعه ايضا موضوع
الهجره من الحدود الجنوبيه مع المكسيك
وفوضى الانسحاب من افغانستان هذا على
الصعيد الداخلي اما خارجيا فربما ينفذ
الجمهوريون التهديداتهم بشان اوكرانيا
نذكره هنا ان رئيس مجلس النواب المرتقب
كهف مكارتي قال انه لا ينبغي ان تمنح
اوكرانيا تشكل على بياض في مساله المساعده
العسكريه لكن امام الجمهوريين مهمه شاقه
للدفع باجندهم يبدا اول فصولها بتوحيد
الاجنده المختلفه داخل الحزب بايدي لم
يتاخر في قراءه هذا الوضع الشائك على فكره
فقد اكد ان الناخبين لا يريدون نزاعا
سياسيا مستمرا وانه يخطط لدعوه قاده الكلى
الحزبين الى البيت الابيض في الاسابيع
المقبله
اماكن
نتائج نتائج
مقدوره تحقيق الوحده اللازمه لاداء المهام
الاساسيه ام ان جناح الصقور في الحزب
سيفرض عليها تغيير خططته جانب اخر اشارت
اليه الصحيفه وهو ان النواب الجمهوريين من
ولايات متارجحه ربما لا يساندون القياده
خاصه ان كانت مشروعات القوانين ستؤثر على
ناخبهم في هذه الولايات هذا عدا عن ان
مقارتي سيحتاج الى اصوات ديمقراطيه لتاييد
بعض مشاريع القوانين التي تتطلب اغلبيه
تفوق ما يحظى به الحزب الجمهوريه هذا
الامر سيفتح الباب لتقديم تنازلات
للديمقراطيين او على اقل تقدير سيفتح باب
للصفقات بين الحزبين بالتاكيد لن تكون مع
نانسي التي اعلنت تخليها قبل ساعات قليله
عن زعامه الديمقراطيين في مجلس لكن على كل
سياسات السير على الحبل الحبل المشدود
ستثير بلا شك غضبا وبن جمهوريين تعاهدوا
قبل ايام فقط بالعمل على ان تسبب ولايتهم
البرلمانيه الما سياسيا كبيرا للرئيس
بايدا وحتى ان تمرير مشاريع القوانين في
مجلس النواب سيكون هناك عائق اخر اين في
مجلس الشيوخ مع سيطره الديمقراطيين عليه
الديمقراطيه دعى الجمهوريين للعمل المشترك
في المبادرات التشريعيه لكنه امر المستبعد
بحسب محللين فلنقسام ليس فقط بين الحزبين
ولكنه يمتد ايضا الى داخل احدهما او على
الاقل
هذا هو الظاهر
[موسيقى]
برنامج الاداره السياسيه في جامعه جورج
واشنطن اهلا بك معنا دكتور في العربيه 360
كيف
تستشرف طبيعه العلاقه بين الحزبين من
داخلهما قبل اي شيء اخر وبينهما بين
بعضهما البعض في تمرير مشاريع القوانين في
داخل الكونجرس بعد هذه الانتخابات
رايق
ومع السيد مكارتي زعيم مجلس النواب
المشكله انه سوف يواجه صعوبات في تحقيق
حاله من الوحده للعمل بين الحزبين وسيد
مكارتي سوف
يمثلوا الجناح المتشدد لحزب الفاهمي
يرغبون باجراء تحقيق اجراء تحقيقات مع
النجم الرئيس مع مجموعه من الوزراء فيما
يتعلق بالهجره والسيد فاوتشي فيما يخص
الاستجابه لكم 19 هؤلاء هم الاشخاص الذين
يرغبوا مكان في النظر في ملفاتهم فضلا عن
جمله من المطالبات لدى الجمهوريه سوف تكون
الامور صعبه على الرئيس
سوف تكون الامور اكثر صعوبه عليه لان يحكم
بسبب الهامش الضيق فالناس قد يكون لديهم
طريقتهم في خدمه
الكونغرس وينتهي الامر بهم بالتخلي عن
مناصبهم لدى سوف يكون لديه هامشا ضيقا
وخاصه في حاله انعدام اي شخص يؤيده لكن
هناك مشكله اخرى
والمشكله الاخرى تكمن في مجلس وفاء ان اي
تشريع ان يرغبوا مكان في ان يصوت عليه
فلابد ان يذهب الى مجلس الشيوخ السؤال
المطروح ما الذي يمكن فعله وفيما يخلص
وفيما يخص جلد فهي لا تحمل الكثير مثل
الثنائي ما نسميه همم
قوانين التخصيص وهي 15 مسوده القانون يجب
تمريرها سنويا من اجل تمويل الميزانيه
وابقاء الحكومه في عمله بصوره الفعاله لدى
هناك فرصه
للتسويه
لاحد الطرفين ليقدم
والعكس صحيح فيما يتعلق بالميزانيه وخلافه
لذلك فان ارفعوا سوف نرى المزيد من
التشريعات وعمليات التحقيقات كما جاء في
تقريركم
بالتالي لن يكون الرئيس هذه المره في حاله
بطه عرجاء كامله كما تسمى همم عندكم انما
ربما سيستطيع امساك العصا من المنتصف اذا
صح التعبير ولكن اضافه الى هذا هل تعتقدون
انه ما يمكن ان يعرقل بسببه ان كان
الديمقراطيون او الجمهوريون للطرف الاخر
هو 2024 الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله ام
انه لا يزال من المبكر التورط في حرب من
هذه من هذا القبيل
الله
الاشياء التي
تسميه مجازيه لكن عندما تكون السيطره لدى
الكونغرس
للتوجه
للترتيبات واجراءات الاداريه لتنفيذ
الامور وهي تشمل ضمن اشياء اخرى اوامر
تنفيذيه
واوامر اداريه تصدر عن مكتب الرئيس التي
يمكن من خلالها الاخيره ان يستخدم
السلطاته دون توجه لكل الكونغرس قد يكون
الامر مسار جدل وقد تكون هناك خسارات في
عقاب ذلك
وتحمل اهميه كبرى وهناك جانب اخر انها سوف
تلقي جو في موضع قوه اذا ما استطاع ان ي-
ان يجعل القضاه يتم تاكيدهم في مجلس
الشيوخ اذا ما حدث ذلك فهذا سوف
يلقي كافه القضاه لسنتين القادمهتين كما
فعل اوباما في السابق بما في ذلك المحكمه
العليا وكما اسلفت الحديث وقد تكون هناك
خسارات كبيره في ما يتعلق بالاوامر
التنفيذيه وفي قضايا الاجهاض لدى لكي
يتسنى للرئيس الاستمرار في ملئ تلك
الفراغات الفضائيه فهذه المساله سوف تكون
محفوفه بالمخاطر لكن العام
2424 ما يزال بعيدا ومن المبكر الاجرائيه
الان عظيم شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الاضاحات
دكتور مدير برنامج الاداره السياسيه في
جامعه جورج واشنطن تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
اقر مجلس محافظين وكاله الذريه قرارا يامر
ايران بالتعاون العاجل مع الوكاله لتحقيق
في اثار اليورانيوم التي عثر عليها في
ثلاثه مواقع غير معلن عنها وهذا القرار
الثاني هذا العام الذي يستهدف ايران بسبب
التحقيق الذي اصبح عقبه في المحادثات بشان
احياء الاتفاق النووي وقالت فرانسبريس ان
سبب هذا القرار هو عدم وجود اجابات ذات
مصداقيه تقنيه فيما يتعلق باثار
اليورانيوم المخصب التي عثر عليها يذكر ان
قرارات الوكاله التي تصدر تحت بند عاجل
وضروري قد تفتح المجال امام احالتها الى
مجلس الامن
[موسيقى]
لن اترك مشكلات ايران الخارجيه ونتحول الى
الداخل ففي شهرها الثالث تتزايد
الاحتجاجات في مختلف المدن بينما تزيد
السلطات جرعه القمع فتحه قوات الامن
الايرانيه النار على اشخاص في محطه مترو
في العاصمه طهران كما قامت بضرب النساء
النساء اللواتي لم يكن يرتدين اغطيه شعر
الزاميه في المحطه واظهرت لقطات تم
تداولها على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ركابا يرقدون نحو المخارج وسقط الكثيرون
منهم ودهسوا بعد ان فتحت الشرطه النار على
منصه المتحده كما صورت لقطه اخرى افرادا
من الشرطه يسيرون الداخل عربات المترو
ويضربون النساء بالهراوات في الاونه
الاخيره اصبحت محطات المترو ووسائل النقل
العام موقعا لعنف السلطات ومراقبه
المواطنين المحتجين نظرا لمحدوديه المكان
مقارنه بالتظاهرات التي تخرج في الشوارع
وقبل الاحت كان رئيس ما تسمى بشرطه
الاخلاق قال ان الحكومه تخطط لاستخدام
تقنيه التعرف على الوجوه لاستهداف النساء
غير الملتزمات بالزي المناسب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بيزيد
[موسيقى]
امس كان من اكثر الايام دمويه حيث سقط 15
قتيلا سبعه منهم في مدينه اذاج شمال شرق
مدينه الاحواز من بين القتلى الاحتجاجات
من بين قتل الاحتجاجات بحسب منظمات حقوقيه
طفل في التاسعه من عمره كان يجلس في
السياره رفقه والده عندما اطلقت عليه قوه
البسيج النار
نذكر دائما بانه وافقا لمنظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه قتل اكثر من 300 شخص
على ايدي قوات الامن خلال شهرين
الاحتجاجات بينما اعتقلت السلطات واكثر من
الفا اخرين مؤخرا عمد المحتاجون الى تحصيل
شوارعهم واقامه المتاريس تحسبا للصدام مع
قوه الامن التي زادت من مستوى العنف ضدهم
بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لكن بينما ينتقد العالم كله قال ان
الايراني اشاد اعضاء في البرلمان به
وصوتوا باغلبيه الساحقه مع العقوبات
القاسيه على المشاركين في الاحتجاجات
والتي قد تصل الى الاعدام اللافت بين
هؤلاء النواب زهره الهيان عضو البرلمان
التي ايدت عقوبه الاعدام وحضت الامم
المتحده على القدوم الى ايران لترى ما
وصفته بالتقدم الذي احرزته المراه
الايرانيه انهيان دعت العالم لعدم تصديق
التقارير الاعلاميه حول ايران
واعددت بعضا مما رسمتها الانجازات التي
حققتها الحكومه للنساء الايرانيات
وللمفارقه كانت الهيام شاركت برفقه كاظم
غريبه بادي وهو نائب رئيس السلطه القضائيه
الايرانيه في اجتماع للجمعيه العموميه
للامم المتحده وللمفارقه الاكبر اعتمد هذا
الاجتماع قرارا لصالح القضاء على جميع
اشكال العنف ضد النساء والفتيات
[موسيقى]
الاضراب الذي شهدته مختلف المدن الايرانيه
خصوصا في العاصمه طهران دفع مجله نيوز ويك
للمقارنه بين الوضع حاليا والوضع خلال
الايام الاخيره لشاه ايران في السلطه
ورصدت المجله العوامل المشتركه بين
الحدثين وفي مقدمتها اضراب البازار الكبير
في طهران وهو مركز ثقل لاقتصادي مهم وكان
يمثل رابطا بين رجال الدين وتجار الطبقه
الوسطى الذين دعموا ثوره
1979 من القرن الماضي المجله اشارت الى ان
المختلف الان هو دور وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي مع بقاء رمزيه البازار
التاريخيه وسائل التواصل تطيح للمحتاجين
امكانيه التخطيط والتنظيم وان حاولت
السلطات قطع الانترنت في ايران
الى ان نجاح الثوره ضد الشاه كانت لانه لم
يستخدم العنف اما النظام الايراني فيبدو
انه اخذ على نفسه عهدا بان لا يفعل مثل
الشاه وان يستخدم القمع الى اخر مدى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وصل ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى تايلاند في زياره رسميه وذلك
بعد زياره الى كوريا الجنوبيه شهدت توقيع
اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم في قطاعات مختلفه
نتعرف على ابرز محطات هذه الزياره في
التقرير الاتيه
زياره ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى المحطه الثانيه ضمن جولته
الاسيويه كوريا الجنوبيه اختتمت باعلان
صفقات واستثمارات تتجاوز قيمتها عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات لتاخذ البلدين الى
درجه اعلى من التقارب الاقتصادي والتجاريه
خلال الزياره عقد الامير محمد بن سلمان
جلسه مباحثات اولى مع رئيس الوزراء هاندا
سو تناوله فيها سبل تعزيز العلاقات
والتعاون المشترك في مختلف المجالات ثلاثه
جلسه مباحثات رسميه عقدها ولي العهد
السعودي بحضور وحزين من البلدين حيث كان
على راس الوفد الكوري رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
يونس يوكيو اكد خلال هذه الامير محمد بن
سلمان على عمق العلاقه وان كوريا الجنوبيه
تعد شريكا استراتيجيا للسعوديه على مدى ال
60 عاما الماضي
على ان شاء الله هات بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا مما يؤكد رغبه
بلدينا في الاستمرار في ترسيخ اسس هذه
العلاقه التاريخيه والعمل على استكمال
الجهود الراميه الى تعزيز التعاون في جميع
المجالات
مستقبل استثماري ضخم بين الرياض وصول حيث
جرى خلال زياره ابرام 25 عقدا ومذكره
تفاهم بقيمه 29 مليار دولار وضمن جدول
زيارته التقى ولي العهد السعودي عددا من
رؤساء كبرى الشركات الكوريه واستعرض معهم
فرص الاستثمار في التكنولوجيا والصناعه
والتشييد والمدن الذكي تعاون وثيق جمع
بلدين ضمن اطار الرؤيه السعوديه الكوريه
2030 وتنسيق استثماري عالا عزز من الشراكه
الممتده لسته عقود
في العربيه 360 ايضا
واسطانه الحرب الاوكرانيه تطعم الجميع من
خيرات ارضك وياتي عليك اليوم
لتتسول غذاءك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
لتداول العملات المشفره هز السوق
وطرح اسئله كبيره هو هي حتى الان من دون
اجابات لكن الامور مع اعلان اعضاء في لجنه
الخدمات الماليه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
نيتهم عقد اجتماع الشهر المقبل للتحقيق في
انهيار ثاني اكبر لتبادل العملات المشفره
في العالم اللجنه قالت
انها تتوقع الاستماع لافادات مؤسس منصه
وكذلك الى شركه التجاريه على
سي وايضا من اصل اكبر والمنافسه الاولى
باينس انهيار
جسيما باكثر من مليون مستخدم كثيرون منهم
كانوا اشخاصا عاديين اسمر مدخراتهم
المكتسبه بشق الانفس في المنصه
[موسيقى]
تقدمت افتي اكس بطلب الحمايه من الافلاس
في الحادي عشر من نوفمبر الجاري واستقال
باكمان فرايد من منصب الرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه يعني الافلاس ان وقت طويلا سيمضي
قبل ان يتمكن عملاء ودائنوا الشركه من
استرداد اموالهم هذا ان وجدت
يحققوا مكتب المدعي العام في منحه بانهيار
اف تي اكس امر يسلط الضوء على مستقبل
صناعه العملات الرقميه ككل وتفيد صحيفه
واشنطن بوست بان التحقيق اظهر ان من الصطع
اعتمدت عمليه احتلال قديمه الطراز ظن
عملاها ان اموالهم محفوظه بامان لكن
المنصه مررتها على ما يبدو لاستخدامها في
المضاربه الصحيفه استغربت موقف كل من لجنه
الاوراق الماليه والبورتات الامريكيه
ولجنه تداول السلعه
وهما اللتان لم تفعل شيئا يذكر حتى الان
على الاقل
قبل انهيار اف تي اكس وضع المؤسس الملايين
في جهود الوقايه من الاوبئه وسمحت له ثوره
الانفاق على جماعات الضغط والمساهمات في
الحملات وخبراء الاتصالات السياسيه
بالوصول الى اروقه السلطه وتامين لقاءات
مع رئيسه مجلس النواب الديمقراطيه نانسي
بيلوسي و زعيم الاقل في مجلس الشيوخ نجمه
كامل اليوم توقفت معظم جهود باكمان فرايد
مع اخيه غابي ايضا الذي يعمل في الكونجرس
في دعم قطاع الصحه العامه ما سيؤثر سلبا
على التقدم في هذا المجال الحياوي لقد
كانت تبرعات الشاب ثري سابقا سخيه بما
يكفي لسد العوز قال سام باتمان برايد
سابقا امام لجنه كورونا ان الشيء الذي
يقلقه اكثر هو جائه اكثر
لكن الجائحه التي ضربت شركته قضت على
ملياراته ال16
مليارا لتكون بالنسبه اليها على الاقل
اقصى من كوفد الذي عرفناه والذي يمكن ان
نعرفه لاحقا
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر معنا من دبي كريم فريد مؤسسه
اهلا بك معنا يا استاذ كريم في العربيه
360 ما عرفتش تشرح لنا شو اللي صار وهل
يشبه ذلك في عالم العملات المشفره ما حصل
في
2009 مع علي من براذرز والازمه الماليه
العالميه وهل هناك تاثير لهذا العالم على
ذاك
بالتاكيد الازمه مشابهه من حيث الافلاس
والانهيار الكبير لشركه من اكبر الشركات
الموجوده في عالم العملات الرقميه
والمشابه للمن برازر وكان من اكبر البنوك
ودمها وقتها ولكن للاسف واللي بنكتشفه مع
مرور الايام ومع تقديم ال ال الملف
للمحكمه للافلاس لكن بنكتشف ان في عمليات
فساد كبيره بتحصل داخل المنصه واساء
الاستخدام الاموال واساء لاستخدام اموال
المذيعين بشكل رئيسي
وهمم اساءه حتى في الجوانب اداريه بسيطه
جدا همم ازمه مهوله بتضرب ثقه مش بس في
عالم العملات الرقميه ولكن فعلا رياده
الاعمال كذلك ان
المدن اللي بنعتمد عليه وعرفناه خلال
السنين 10 سنين اللي فاتوا ان عالم يد
الاعمال على مرن سهل بيتم فيه الاداره
بسرعه لتحقيق نتائج في اللحظه الحاليه كل
هذه الامور فيها شك محل شك بشكل كبير جدا
همم
الفلاس هذا سيؤثر على القطاع المالي
العالمي ان تطور مثلا ان سقطت من السطات
اخرى ام من انهما منفصلان تماما لا تبعات
تذكره على القطاع المالي التقليدي
همم
في اللحظه الحاليه ما فيش احد يقدر يتوقع
مدى التاثير ولكن كل اللي نقدر نعمله ان
احنا نستنى ونتابع ونشوف مين ايه الروابط
اللي موجوده ما بين شركات سهم لان سهم
امبراطوريته حوالي 130 شركه متداخله بشكل
كبير جدا مع مؤسسات تمويل واستثمار وبنوب
وهمم في عالم العملات الرقميه
اموالهم تماما الان
محدش يقدر يعرف كذلك لان الامر امام
المحكمه هتطلع لحظه بيتم حصر الاصول
[موسيقى]
الليضلتيز او
الاموال المدعين وغير ذلك
وهنستنى المحكمه تخلص الحصر ونبتدي نشوف
ايه الموضوع لكن في كل الاحوال للاسف
المذيعين والمستثمرين قدامهم وقت طويل جدا
ممكن يوصل ل 10 سنين او اكثر عشان يقدروا
ياخذوا فلوسهم مره ثانيه
يعني بدون اسماء همم عليهم يعني يقلقوا ان
يخشوا على امواله على اموالهم
هو افضل افضل بالتاكيد الحذر واجب لان
ثاني ما نقدرش نعرف مدى انتشار الفيروس
حينتشر لغايه فين ما نقدرش نعرف ولكن
الافضل ال ال التكنولوجيا نفسها تكنولوجيا
البلوكشن لازالت سليمه ولازالت قويه من كل
النواحي الافضل ان كل المستثمري لو انت
بتستثمر في العملات الرقميه تحتفظ بها على
محفظه خارجيه محفظه بارده تقدر انك انت
توصل لها في اي لحظه مش في حيازه اي منصه
حتى يتم فرض قيود همم قانونيه واضحه على
المنصات لحمايه اموال العملاء مثل القناه
المشفره شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ كريم
مؤسسمان دبي تحياتنا لايك شكرا على هذه
التوضيحات
[موسيقى]
الى الموجز الرياضي الان مع محمد القناص
شكرا جزيلا طاهر اخبار الرياضه حياكم الله
يعني نهائيات مونديال قطر 2022 اصابته في
صدقه اليمنى حسب ما اعلن الخميس المنتخب
تغلب المنتخب الاسبانيه على نظيره الاردني
بثلاثه اهداف لهدف اليوم الخميس في مباراه
وديه دوليه ضمن استعداداته لنهائيات كاس
العالم 2022 في قطر وتقدم المنتخب
الاسباني عن طريق عين صفاتي في الدقيقه
الثالثه عشر قبل ان يضيف جافي الهدف
الثاني في الدقيقه 56 في الدقيقه الرابعه
والثمانين سجل نيكو ويليامز الهدف الثالث
للمنتخب الاسباني فيما سجل حمزه الدردور
هدف الاردن الوحيد في الدقيقه الثانيه من
الوقت المحتسب بدل الضائع ويتواجد المنتخب
الاسباني في المجموعه الخامسه بكاس العالم
الى جانب منتخبات المانيا وكوستاريكا
واليابان فيما سيتعرف المنتخب الاردني على
منافسه في امم اسيا حينما تجري قرعه
البطوله
اعرب مدرب ومنتخب التونسي جلال القادري عن
ارتياحه لجاهزيه اللاعبين قبل انطلاق
نهائيات كاس العالم وفزت تونس وديا امام
ايران بهدفين دون مقابل امس الاربعاء قبل
خوض المنافسات المجموعه الرابعه للمونديال
الى جانب الدنمارك وفرنسا واستراليا وقال
القادري في تصريحات لصفحه الرسميه للاتحاد
التونسي لكره القدم احنا جاهزيه اللاعبين
فرديا وجماعيا كبيره وتابع هذه المشاركه
السادسه لتونس في المونديال ونعملوا في
تخطي الدور الاول للمره الاولى
فاذا منتخب المغرب بثلاثيه نظيفه على
منتخب جورجيا بالشارقه في الامارات باخر
مباراه وديه استعدادا لنهائيات كاس العالم
لكره القدم في قطر ضغط على المغرب الذي
سانده الاف المشجعين يتقدم بعد مرور خمس
دقائق فتره تمريره عرضيه من الجهه اليمنى
من المتالق حكيم زياش وجده راسيه يوسف
نصيري واضاف حكيم زياش الهدف الثاني بعد
التسديده من منتصف الملعب غلط بها حارسه
جورجيا وتمكن المنتخب المغربي من الحصول
على ركله جزاء نفذها بنجاح سفيان بوفال في
الشوط الثاني ويستاهل الاسود الاطلس
المشاركه السادسه في كاس العالم
بمواجهه المنتخب الكرواتيا الاربعاء
المقبل
هناك شرائح داخل المدرجات 6-0 نتيجه من
الناحيه المعنويه تحفيز جيد للمنتخب
المغربي
ومنتخب الارجنتين ليونيل ميسي عن
المنتخبات المرشحه في كاس العالم كما تحدث
لي ايضا عن مستقبله بعد كره القدم
اعتقد ان البرازيل فرنسا هو انجلترا هي
الابرز والاقوى لكن البطوله صعبه ومعقده
ورددوا دائما بانني لا ارى نفسي كمدرب بعد
ذلك كره القدم مهنه تدريب لا تجذبني لكن
من يدري من الممكن ان نقوم بذلك في الغد
كل شيء قد يتغير بسرعه لم اقرر اي شيء بعد
بالامكان ان يتغير كل شيء ومن الممكن ان
ارحل للامانه انا لا اعلم ما قد يحدث في
المستقبل
اعلن الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم فيفا
الخميس ان رئيسه السويسري جاني انفنتينو
سيكون المرشح الوحيد في مارسي المقبل
لولايه الثالثه تواليا وقالت هيئه
العالميه في بيان قبل ثلاثه ايام على
انطلاق نهائيات كاس العالم في قطر انها لم
تستقبل اي ترشيح اخر من قبل الاتحادات
الاعضاء فيفا قبل المؤتمر الانتخابيه
المقرر في كذلك في السادس عشر من مارس
2023 وكان انفنتينا تقبل للمره الاولى في
عام 2016 بوعد السعاده فيفا الذي كان
وقتها غارقا في سلسله فضائحه فساد عالميه
اطلق الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم فيفا خدمه
حمايه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اس ام بي
اس للتصدي للتمييز وحمايه الصحه النفسيه
للاعبين ورفائهم بالتعاون مع الاتحاد
الدولي للاعبين المحترفين فيث برو ذلك قبل
ايام من انطلاق كاس العالم في قطر من خلال
هذه الخدمه سيتمكدوا جميع اللاعبين من
جميع الاتحادات الاعضاء المشاركه في كاس
العالم من الوصول الى خدمه مخصصه للمراقبه
والابلاغ والحجم مصمم لتقليل ظهور خطاب
الكراهيه الموجه اليهم على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بالتالي يمكن حمايه اللاعبين
ومشجعين من النساء عبر الانترنت خلال
البطوله ذلك بحسب الموقع الرسمي للاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم على الانترنت
هذه ابرز اخبار رياضه كانت معكم نعود الان
الى طه الاستكمال العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمحمد قالت وسائل الاعلام فلسطينيه
انسا 25 شخصا على الاقل لقوا حتفهم دلاعي
حريق بمنزل في مخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه
وتوجهت قوات كبيره من طواقيم الدفاع
المدني والشرطه للتعامل مع الحريق الذي
رجح مسؤول ان يكون قد نشب نتيجه تخزين
كميات كبيره من البنزين في المنزل
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 يمكننا
اعاده النظر في علاقتنا مع الدول التي
لدينا معها مشاكل ويمكننا القيام بذلك بعد
انتخابات يونيو الرئاسيه التصريح هو
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ردا على
سؤال عن العلاقه مع القاهره ودمشق واضاف
اردوغان انه ليس هناك خلاف واستياب في
السياسه ويمكن ليس هناك خلاف ابدي في
السياسه ويمكن تقييم الوضع عندما يحل
الوقت هو اردوغان نفسه الذي وصف يوما بشار
الاسد بالارهابي واعتبر ان رحيله حتمي وان
التعامل معه مستحيل
الى صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 وهي من مصر
بشوش الوجه ابيض القلب يجمع ابيض الزهر في
موسم حصاد القطن قد بدا عاما بعد عام
يتكرر الزرع وتتكرر الفرحه بطول دلتا
النيل يترك كل حصاد يترك كل حصاد شقا في
التربه واخر في وجوه وايادي الحاصدين لا
يعرف هؤلاء انه على بعد مئات كيلوميترات
في شرم الشيخ تحديدا هناك من يناقش مستقبل
قطنهم اضافه الى مستقبلهم لو استمر تغير
المناخ كما هو لن يكون هناك قط ولن تكون
هناك فرحه لانه اصلا لن تكون هناك دلتا
فيديو اليوم من خير سنه حيث تشتعل الحرب
وحين تشتعل تتبدل احوال الناس من حال الى
حال خيصون التي كانت يوما ما احدى سلال
الغذاء الاوكرانيه يقف فيها الناس في صفوف
طويله لانتظار المساعدات
تغير المسيطر على المدينه من اوكرانيا الى
روسيا الى اوكرانيا مره اخرى لكن المعاناه
لم تتغير قبل عام كان الاوكرانيون ياكلون
فاكهه تخصصون ويدعون لمن زرعها اليوم
يدعونهم لاهالي خرصان كي يجدوا ما ياكل